after a three year wait the next wonder
woman installment is here
wonder woman 1984 serves as yet another
thrilling installment in diana's modern
day story
that said it still left some unanswered
questions in its wake
here are the biggest unanswered
questions in wonder woman 1984 wonder
woman 1984 opens on the secret amazonian
island of themaskira during diana's
childhood
in an incredibly arduous sort of amazon
style olympic games diana despite being
years younger than her competitors
easily takes first place before falling
behind when the race is nearly finished
though she finds a shortcut and regains
first place her aunt the warrior antiope
pulls her out of the running telling her
that she cheated and can't win if she
doesn't do it honestly
however the existence of these games in
general raises some questions
none of which get answered what are
these games called and how often are
they held
why is diana a literal child even
allowed to compete against adult
amazonian warriors
also how are the competitors chosen are
they from noble families like diana or
they chosen from a larger group and what
do they win when they take first place
in these games
shortly after she gets started at the
smithsonian barbara shows off some of
her discoveries to diana including a
mysterious stone with an ancient
language written along its base
ultimately the two discover that the
dreamstone can grant wishes but the
dreamstone's exact origin is never
specifically revealed
diana and barbara do discover that the
stone was crafted by the god of mischief
and treachery and will grant any wish
though in doing so it steals a person's
most cherished ability
which can only be reversed that the
person takes their wish back or if the
stone itself is destroyed
however we never learned where the stone
came from and much of its backstory
remains a mystery
as the film introduces us to diana's
lonely life in dc
the camera pants across the shelves of
her apartment which contained photos
from throughout her life as well as
steve's watch
which he gave her right before he
sacrificed his life in the war
these photos which chronicle several
adventures in diana's life include one
that raises some questions
diana posing in front of a pastoral area
with a sign that reads trevor ranch
while this is clearly a sweet gesture it
also raises some big questions the most
obvious of which is
what and where exactly is trevor ranch
did the ranch already exist within
steve's family and did diana visit and
meet them
or did diana start it as a tribute to
her fallen love what does trevor ranch
do exactly
aside from the fact that it bears
steve's name we still know nothing about
trevor ranch
after barbara and diana make their
initial wishes on the stone maxwell uses
an unwitting newly competent barbara to
gain access to the artifact and does
something completely unprecedented
he becomes the stone itself by wishing
to be the human embodiment to the
dreamstone
in doing so he wrecks his body but also
earns unprecedented power using his
ability to grant wishes to manipulate
people throughout the world into doing
his bidding
eventually diana with her powers
restored uses the lasso of truth to
speak through maxwell as he broadcasts
his own image across the world
and begs people to recant their own
wishes however this doesn't really
answer the question of what happens to
the stone when maxwell recants
does this destroy the dreamstone
altogether or does it still live within
him ready to grant wishes once again
throughout his time as a human
embodiment to the dreamstone maxwell
accomplishes a lot
maxwell becomes uncorrupted when he
recants after he's subdued by diana
reuniting with his son and promising to
be a better father
however the fact still remains that
maxwell did some pretty abominable
things during his tenure as the
dreamstone and despite being returned to
reality it seems like maxwell should
probably be held accountable for
everything he did
does maxwell ever face any legal
consequences for everything he does as
the dreamstone
if so perhaps it's possible that he'd be
cleared of all charges deemed unable to
control himself while his body was more
or less possessed by a mythical force
as maxwell manipulates unsuspecting
people into making rash wishes that end
up serving his bottom line we see people
across the world making a ton of crazy
requests
under maxwell's dreamstone rule the
world ends up on the brink of nuclear
war becoming a crazed apocalyptic place
that looks absolutely terrifying
by the time the film ends it's a holiday
season and we see diana as she happily
watches families play together at a
local christmas village in dc
however the fact remains that everybody
celebrating christmas this year seems
well suspiciously happy after the
cataclysmic events of the entire film
this raises the question do humans
remember any of their wish-induced lives
or was it wiped from their memory
allowing them to move on
steve trevor sacrificed himself in the
first wonder woman film viewers spent
three years wondering if he'd return
thanks to the dreamstone steve does
return in the sequel and though his and
diana's romance is short-lived once
again they still get some time together
in the 1980s before diana makes her own
grand sacrifice
wonder woman 3 was recently confirmed
with jenkins at the hound but she
previously said she'd only return if the
film would get a fully theatrical
release
as far as good out is concerned she
wouldn't even want to do the film if
pine doesn't make another miraculous
comeback
godot told entertainment tonight i
couldn't imagine doing another one
without him the fact that they figured
out the right way to bring him back that
actually helps the story it was
delightful to work with him again and it
felt like coming back home
working with patty and with chris and
with our wonderful crew there's no word
on it pine would be willing to return
but the question of whether steep can
come back from the dead a second time
still remains
i wish we had more time
when barbara first arrives at the
smithsonian she's meek and shy flying
under the radar thanks to a spectacular
lack of confidence
though diana initially turns down
barbara's first lunch invitation the two
begin to bond over ancient artifacts
leading diana to invite barbara out for
drinks after work
over whining cocktails diana opens up to
barbara saying she admires her new
friend's open nature and even admits
that she has largely closed herself off
emotionally which is more than diana
typically gives to anyone in her life
after maxwell and the rest of the world
recant their wishes barbara transforms
back into a human being
and we never see her again it does seem
like diana and barbara have a genuine
connection
especially after they've both been
affected by the dreamstone do they ever
rekindle their friendship
have you ever been in love a long long
time ago
you so many times yeah all the time
the dream stone is definitely too good
to be true which is the fact that
maxwell and barbara both learn pretty
quickly
as barbara gives up all of her humanity
and maxwell's body literally crumbles
under the pressure being the stone
itself
there's no question that the dreamstone
can be used for evil which leads one to
wonder if it could also be used for a
significantly less selfish reason
both barbara and maxwell use the
dreamstone to gain power and strength
but the way diana uses it raises some
interesting questions
though diana is already plenty powerful
as an amazonian and doesn't need the
dreamstone to wish for that
her wish to bring steve back is
extraordinarily personal and doesn't
seem as if it could cause any adverse
effects
except for the stranger's body that
steve seems to hijack
considering how even diana's wish isn't
immune to corruption
is it even possible to use the
dreamstone for good and not evil
if you watch wonder woman 1984 closely
you might notice that the actress
playing asteria
an ancient legendary amazon warrior
whose gold armor helps diana defeat
maxwell and barbara looks pretty
familiar
in fact that actress is none other than
linda carter who made the character of
wonder woman famous during the
television series in the 1970s
as if that wasn't enough carter pops up
in a mid-credit sequence which reveals a
stunning fact
asteria like diana secretly lives among
humans
naturally this raises an enormous
question will carter ever appear aside
gadot who took over the mantle of wonder
woman for the big screen in a possible
sequel
it's entirely possible that both
carter's cameo and credit sequence are
simply easter eggs for longtime wonder
woman fans but it also brings up the
exciting possibility that carter and
geddadz could join forces as hysteria
and diana in future wonder woman
projects
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one